ich weiß viele von euch werden
enttäuscht sein oder
mich kreuzigen aber ich sage euch eins
ich bin ein großer unterstützer des
böllerverbot ich befürworte ein
böllerverbot schon seit jahren ich finde
das überfällig und ich sag euch aus
abgesehen davon dass ich aus corona
gründen verstehe ich nicht finden
sollten mehr an die frische luft aber
selbst sind ja selbstverständlich
müssen die kliniken entlastet werden und
die haben moment anderes zu tun als sich
um
abgesprengte hände und und
körperverletzungen zu sorgen aber das
zweite zweite grund ist ich lebe in
berlin das ist am ich erlebe des
silvesternacht als kriegsschauplatz und
ich lebe in charlottenburg in einem
relativ bürgerlichen bezirk es ist
gefährlich dort auf die straße zu gehen
ist liegen kreuz und quer die feuerwerke
die am nächsten tag sieht das aus wie
ein vorort von von von beirut ich finde
es entsetzlich müll müll ich finde ich
finde es entsetzlich dieses diese dieses
dieses bildern und ein paar fun fact wir
verbrennen wir reden immer geld sparen
und und um die inflation und all das wir
wir verbrennen
150 200 millionen euro allein die
verfahren in die luft freuen ich finde
das fast dekadenten noch ein fun fact
ich bin kein klima aktivist aber dieser
eine nacht mit
4500 tonnen feinstaub in die luft
geblasen das ist fast ein fünftel von
dem was im gesamten jahr durch den
straßenverkehr verursacht wird es kann
doch nicht sein dass wir ständig darüber
nachdenken für die e-autos und alle da
sind dann in einer nacht und einfach
leisten weil ein fünftel des gesamten
jahres aufkommens an feinstaub man
ebenso völlig sinnlos in die luft zu
schießen ich befürworte 1 1 ein
grundsätzliches
nein da gama hat vorhin gesagt die
freiheit endet meiner freiheit des
anderen ich fühle mich immer ich fühle
mich in der silvesternacht in seiner
sicherheit bedroht ich finde mich ich
mag den lernen nicht und ich mag den
müll nicht das geht so kosten ob meine
freiheit bitte leute gibt das geld
vernünftiger aus als die böller
alexander es gibt sehr gut sekunde für
böller verbot aber es kann man doch
heute sehr überraschen und ich finde der
zeitpunkt wann ein bisschen unding weil
jetzt im dezember ein böller verbot zu
verhängen das tun wir vor allen dingen
die unternehmer leid weil die machen zu
silvester in jahresumsatz und sie haben
jetzt schon ihr personal eingestellt die
ganze ware liegt schon bei ihnen wir
haben anfang dezember eine ware die
übrigens hauptsächlich aus china
importiert wird wo sie uns unter
menschenrechtsverachtenden
bedingungen hergestellt wird dann dürfen
wir aber ganz viele nicht mehr benutzen
ja das ist ja das ist wahr dass das ist
wahr das ist war also ich benutze auch
kein auto richtig verstehe es auch nicht
als kommune zu machen haben also wenn
dann es gibt viele gründe man kann auch
den tierschutz versprochen mit
den tierschutz auch noch verbreitet ist
übrigens der zeitpunkt ist sehr
ungünstig und eben unter dem vorwand der
kommune schutzmaßnahmen für das ob so
ein bisschen absurd aber ich finde es
total faszinierend dass alexander hier
in ein und derselben sendung john blog
zitiert den großen freiheit philosophen
in derselben sendung für ein verbot ist
also ganz ehrlich ich bin auch kein
brüller aber ich finde zur freiheit
gehört auch die freiheit zum wahnsinn
und zum blödsinn ich verstehe das nicht
und das ist privates geld was wieder
ausgeben das sind ist es wahnsinnig viel
150 millionen 150 millionen euro jahr
viel geld aber hey die leute sollen
selber entscheiden was mit ihrem geld
machen das wäre
aber ich sage dir die freiheit endet ja
also in die endet ja an meiner haustür
und ich muss sagen ich habe lange an der
hauptstraße in berlin-charlottenburg
gewohnt jetzt gott sagen in der
seitenstraße du konntest dich nicht
gemein weil am balkon aufhalten weil die
leute machen sich einen spaß daraus
nicht in luft zu schießen eine quer quer
zu schießen und meine kinder können hier
raus auf den milizen seepark gesenkt auf
keinen fall bekommt ihr kommt ein paar
verbrennungs und das ist ein
kriegsschauplatz vor der tür dass er hat
dass das hat nichts mehr mit in die
freiheit des einzelnen zu tun ja ich hab
immer geballert in meiner kindheit und
ich liebe feuerwerk ich liebe feiern
nämlich alles zurücknehmen
und deine damen ist alles blödsinn ich
liebe feuerwerk und ich werde meinen
silvester auch dieses jahr in rom
verbringe ich glaube weil ich schon
abkommen sehen und ich habe letztes jahr
schon keine feuerwerk ich brauche vor
allem für das neue jahr an dem in
italien also instrumente noch feuerwerk
auf der dachterrasse okay ich mein
selbstvertrauen kann er ist ja nicht
überall usus dass das überall feuer
seien aufgebraucht das ducati allen
ebenen des jahres vorher werk auf
twitter google kaufen wieder die farben
werde für mein seelenheil bin ich gut
gelaunt nächstes jahr wieder hier im
stall bin aber was ich auch sagen möchte
ist ich habe jetzt meine kindheit
angesprochen aber was sehr persönliches
hat er schon fast ein bisschen
stammtischniveau wenn kinder erzählt
aber es ist nichts gegen stammten
absichtlich aber es hat ja auch was ein
brauch es ist eine erinnerung ist es ist
auch etwas was wir haben in der
gesellschaft es ist einfach das neue
jahr begrüßen wir damit ich muss ehrlich
sagen wenn wir jetzt anfangen wenn jeder
sagen kann was ihn stört und damit
beschränken wir die freiheit des anderen
dürfen wir fast gar nichts mehr und du
alexander ich bin so erschrocken ist was
heute bringst du bist doch auch für die
freiheit haben aber auch in aschau wir
morgen schon einmal die straßen angeht
man am morgen des ersten ihr arbeitet ja
alle im ersten jahr und nicht weil aber
ich merke ich immer freiwillig zum
dienst an silvester nur für bin muss ich
zugeben ich bin sein kindliches ist mit
dem ich überhaupt nichts anfangen kann
aber bitte geht einmal über die über die
berlin auf die straßen frühmorgens am
ernten anderes ist absolut gegeben weil
ich eine straße während des oktoberfests
in münchen und das heißt würde man doch
auch nicht verbieten wollen also das
wirst du auch nicht verbieten wollen
aber es ist das mittel ordentlich am
oktoberfest lockt da stehen sie zu dem
platz ich habe ja ich habe da jetzt 22
herzen eigentlich in einer busse auf
einmal auf einer seite geben wir
vollkommen recht ist ist findig kommt
zur unzeit wenn dann kommt es viel zu
spät
auch in hinsicht auf die unternehmer
dann sehe ich natürlich auch nicht was
das jetzt so bringen soll hinsichtlich
dass man sagt okay die krankenhäuser
sollen nicht voll sein ob das wirklich
so ist weiß ich nicht aber auf der
anderen seite freue ich mich natürlich
für die vier tiere also meine tiere das
war ganz ganz schlimm an silvester
gewesen die haben sich schon ein paar
tage vorher schon immer verkrochen
gehabt und haben zum zittern angefangen
riecht irre führen terminkalender ihre
tiere haben das merken die weil
natürlich immer schon ein paar tage
vorher
natürlich in die luft und das bekommen
die mit ist im büro wenn sie zum
tierarzt geht ja ja auch irgendwie weiß
nicht warum aber sie mag
7 und jan auch wenn ich an die vielen
tiere denke in der freien natur
natürlich wie es ist also in diesem
gesichtspunkt natürlich freue ich mich
darüber aber ich habe jetzt zwei herzen
in einer brust und das mit den
krankenhäusern kann ich auch nicht
beweisen ich kann nur sagen in berlin an
einer silvesternacht hörten sie ständig
das martinshorn also die wie ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass sie aus
freizeit aber heute haben schon
virologen widersprochen unter anderem
auch bei bild live mit dem böllerverbot
das ist wirklich aus koronar
gesichtspunkten ist findet ihr auch im
freien statt was ist klar er will hat er
nicht mit 100 leuten im studio und ich
hab es das konkret so entlastung
mitglieder und über viele verletzungen
im abend eingehend das ist glaube ich
evident und man muss dazu sagen wir
hatten ein tolles thema die spaltung der
gesellschaft und erfahrung vielleicht
ist auch gar nicht so schlecht dieses
jahr wohl
angetrunkene leute nichts keinen
sprengstoff in homöopathischen vertreten
ich bin ganz ehrlich haben sie mich
nicht verunsichert und harvey weniger
und so persönliche freiheit auch zu
schätzen wissen ja also ich meine zu
böllern oder ein feuerwerk sehen zu
können wir können doch jetzt auch nicht
immer alles weg in den leuten wurde die
weihnachtsmärkte genommen es wurde so
viel genommen und es gibt viele menschen
millionen die freude daran haben und
mich stört so sehr in unserer
gesellschaft das freude und lebensfreude
keinen berg mehr hat daran geld und
weihnachtsmärkten und das kann man nicht
vergleichen denn wie gesagt ein
weihnachtsmarkt ist ist ist reines
vergnügen das finden einer frischen luft
stadt entsteht dort kein lärm und müll
das gehört wirklich zu unserer kultur
und ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt so ein
kulturgut ist dieses rumballern also ich
würde das würde ich nicht in abrede
stellen also das also dass ich bin ich
bin wirklich dafür ist weihnachten auf
rechtsfolgen jede jede
weihnachtstraditionen ist mir ist mir
heilig aber aber silvesterböllern als
als zentrales kulturgut also das aber
reden wir jetzt über estland cool oder
nicht oder reden wir darüber soll der
staatsreform kümmern oder er lässt erst
riss finde ich also habe ich keine so
richtig starke meinung dazu beim
letzteren habe ich eine sehr starke
meinung dazu das geht den staat
unbedingt was an finde ich also wie
gesagt wenn du eine partei gründet sich
die augen mich dann in deine
fraktionsdisziplin absolut ein aber ich
würde dort tatsächlich immer wieder
argumentieren auch müll und lärm ist
eine belastung und unter dach der staat
schon sagen bitte mach scannen und man
muss klimaschutz muss man ja auch
sozusagen lange es ist sehr
umweltschädlich natürlich der tierschutz
ist also es gibt gute gründe des zug
anbieten ähnlich glaube ich wieder
stierkampf in spanien darüber kann man
ja auch kontrovers diskutieren aber das
ist tradition benedikt hat aber gerade
finde ich einen sehr wichtigen punkt
debattieren wir jetzt darüber ob man das
bürgern sein lassen sollte wegen tieren
wegen umweltschutz oder obwohl der
stahlkonzern wo der staat sich
eingreifen darf und die frage bin ich
ganz gerne an sie spielen frau will wie
sie waren so lange in der politik tätig
in der csu wie sehen sie das denn wie
viel freiheit generell gefragt sollte
der staat lassen und wie sehen sie das
in den letzten monaten sehen sie hier
bestimmt auch damit beschäftigen der
frage ja aber nun kommen wir wieder zu
dem herzen ja vorhin schon gesagt habe
du hast ja ich bin für die freiheit die
freiheit des einzelnen und wir sind ja
auch individuellen deswegen schlimmen
wir unsere freiheit die
eigenverantwortung alles dass wir haben
wir uns nehmen würde ich will nicht dass
der staat über alles bestimmt was ich
tue was ich mache sondern wir müssen die
menschen auch individuen sein lassen
aber es geht natürlich auch nur bis zu
gewissen grenzen und ihm ist natürlich
schon dann auch klar
gesteuert sein ist genau wie ein an der
ampel ist ganz klar wenn die ampel rot
ist dann sind wir halt okay dann haben
wir halt zu halten da kann ich sagen ich
bin ich habe ein gewissen rechtsrahmen
in dem ich mich halten muss und dann war
ich auch nicht über rot grün
es ist ja verboten müll in der natur
abgeladen damit ist auch nicht so dass
ich meine freiheit ein kulturgut ich
möchte ich möchte ich möchte meine alten
ölkanister im wald ab liegt aber da hat
ja auch niemand spaß dran naja gut so
aber er also wie gesagt die freiheit die
freiheit wird der eingeschränkt aus
guten gründen zum beispiel weil es
einfach lernen oder
oder müll verursachen ich bin in der
schweiz ist es so wenn du zu nutzen laut
das auto auf proben lässt kommt die
polizei und sagte das ist
also das ist es gibt ja es gibt ja gute
gründe man hier sieht man manche sachen
so aber ich bin natürlich
unendlicher verfechter der freiheit aber
sie darf eben nicht auf kosten anderer
geschehen und resigniert in dem fall
haben ist einfach eindeutig ich ihre
tiere können nicht schlafen ich möchte
an dem tag um 22 uhr ins bett gehen weil
ich weil ich sie western wofür bin und
man kann den schlaf